Despicable Me 3 is the next third entry
in the animated series of films for kids
that you probably weren't expecting to
see or really caring to see but we're
going to see anyway because they make
money and in this one GRU voiced by
Steve Carell the evil supervillain
turned good guy who has three young
girls he's taken care of and now a wife
voiced by Kristen Wiig discovers he has
a long-lost twin brother and they go on
adventures together including going up
against an evil supervillain who is an
old actor from an 80s TV show who loves
breakdance fighting and shooting people
with bubblegum no I don't want to come
off like I'm a despicable me hater
because I'm obviously not I have the
first two on blu-ray I actually really
enjoyed these movies my wife and I
really like to see them minions was a
little too much for me because I think
those characters work really well as
supporting comedy when they were the
entire movie it just graded on my nerves
a lot so I was like really are we really
needing another Despicable Me movie and
leaving it I'm like really did we really
need another Despicable Me movie this
movie is perfectly enjoyable it's a
light-hearted fun watch but beyond that
I don't really think this movie is
necessary it has a lot of good humor as
a surprising amount of adult humor
there's a lot of mature humor in this
movie that I think a lot of kids aren't
going to get and even some that I think
might be a little too much for kids like
when the minions are passing a statue of
a woman who resembles GRU but she has
breasts the minions like little boobs
and I'm just I'm seeing a lot of young
kids when they see women on the street
going look boobs which might cause some
problems I suppose if I were to boil
down my main issue with this movie is
that despite its adult humour and its
mature themes it only makes jokes about
those things it doesn't really go for
the more gut-wrenching emotion that they
could get out of some of the storylines
in this movie like for instance the two
brothers grew and drew they were
separated at Birth and their parents
were divorced but both parents liked the
other one more but the parents got the
wrong child there could be a lot of
depth there but it's basically just
thought about in one scene and they
never really go anywhere with it there's
even a scene where GRU is talking to his
mom and she mentions how disappointing
he was and it's played for a joke it is
kind of funny
but they just never try to go for that
emotion when there's actually a lot of
mature themes this movie could go for
like a Pixar movie might attempt to do
in something like inside out Despicable
Me 3 tries to use it for a joke and
while I did laughs semi consistently I
just felt like it was a giant missed
opportunity
Steve Carell as GRU is my favorite part
of all the Despicable Me Films I love
his voice the accent I like his
character and I like seeing the
progression of his characters change and
in 1 & 2 you got that there were things
that he had to deal with it he didn't
expect from an emotional standpoint in
this movie yes he doesn't expect that he
has a twin brother but as I said they
play it so much for humor that it felt
like his character just kind of had no
arc he didn't really have anywhere to go
in this movie beyond let's have funny
scenes with my brother because I finally
found my porpoise when I am GRU and now
I have something to do and it's like
okay I get it's funny but the other two
films had more of an emotional punch and
this one seems like it's just played
four straight laughs so the other two
films are films that I think kids and
adults are really going to like three
seems to think that adults are just
there to laugh at some 16 plus level
humor and the kids are there for the
animation where the first two seem to
understand that grown-ups enjoy emotion
as well this one has it it's just almost
always played for Laughs
the main villain of the film is voiced
by Trey Parker of South Park Fame and
there are some aspects of his character
that I think are really funny he has a
gigantic collection of toys of himself
from a TV show that he used to be on
he's very obsessed with that TV show and
wonders why it never won any Emmys you
get to see some clips from it and it is
very funny and after a while the film
just kept recycling the exact same humor
with that character and it felt like
they didn't know where to go with him
they even stole Zoolander's breakdance
fight scene and it was funny but it just
felt like something I had seen before
and better the animation is not to be
overlooked it's spectacular this is more
of a cartoon than a film I would say I
think the first two Despicable Me films
are more animated movies and this one
feels more
a cartoon it's probably my best way to
say it young kids will really like it
adults will have some things to laugh at
but in the end is definitely not as good
as the first two I did like it more than
minions though I'm going to give
Despicable Me 3 a C+ guys thank you for
watching look forward to tomorrow
because I'm going to have my review for
spider-man homecoming I'm really excited
to talk about that one thank you once
again guys you're the best if you liked
this you can click right here and get
steppen eyes
[Music]
you